hey what's going on it's Bill Bird it's
time for the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday September 18th
2020 tree what's going on how why yeah
yeah how's it going did you know how it
went oh yeah the most frustration
frustration of watching my Patriots
yesterday God damn it
frustration of these [__] referees
God damn it how the [__] you [__]
say without a doubt
without a doubt that wasn't a first down
you couldn't even see the [__] ball
and then what do they do they go if then
then the [__]
the goddamn uh uh uh mouth of the
[__] um
it's like that person that comes out for
the president when the president doesn't
want to talk the press secretary comes
out there uh we're not talking about
that right now uh no it's exactly how we
said it was gonna be despite your
questions I'm not answering that right
they got that [__] jerk off comes on
he goes well you know with the cameras
like right online with this thing it
wasn't right online with the play it was
a little bit [__] off
he didn't land near a hash mark how in
the [__]
how in the [__] can you call that back
I'm not even saying that like
it wasn't the right call I'm not even
saying that but I'm like there's not
enough [__] information there I don't
know whether it was or whether it wasn't
I couldn't tell and on the field you
said it was a first down somehow they
were able to [__] tell
the [__] out of here
I was 2-0 with my bets and I was going
all right maybe I'll go three and one
who knows I might go 4-0 and then I
[__] watching the Jets game they go
down 10 to nothing Jets were my lock of
the week
that is ten to seven
and then they have in this great
[__] goal line stand
or whatever you know maybe hold them to
a field goal and they call two brutal
roughing the passer calls that even Tony
Romo who still sleeps in Dallas Cowboy
pajamas goes yeah those were a couple of
50 50 calls well all right then why
didn't one of them go the Jets way
they both go against the [__] Jets
they go down two scores
and then their [__] quarterback he's
got to play catch-up and then that was
just the end of the [__] game
so sorry to everybody with my lock of
the week you know
God damn it
whatever I want two other games I did
give you the Colts over the Texans and I
was I'm two and two both weeks
so I'm four and four
I'll tell you what was really [__] up
man how about how about Sean McVay going
for that random field goal at the end of
the game that affected the spread
they're down 30 to 20. with like four
seconds left
all right I don't know what the [__]
spread was but I do know what it
affected the spread it swung it from the
Rams not covering to them covering
all right and here's the thing they'll
hide behind at the end of the year you
know if it comes down to a tie breaker
of points scored that three points will
[__] add up that's what they'll say
they'll say some dumb [__] like that
right and you know what I say to that
people
there is a reason why
the entire time I was growing up
and like 70 years before I was growing
up that players were not allowed
to gamble on sports
right
because the [__] temptation
to affect the lines would corrupt the
game and if they corrupted the game
everyone will be like [__] this this
game's [__] and they would stop
watching that's back when they actually
thought we had something better to do
now they've completely gotten in bed
with them
the owners too
and I'm supposed to sit there and think
that only the players who now a couple
of them already gotten suspended for
gambling on games only the players are
are susceptible susceptible to being
corrupted by the Temptations of gambling
but what the owners have so much [__]
money huh
they don't have some side piece they're
trying to keep [__] happy and all of
a sudden they tell chunch kick the why
the [__] did he kick a field goal there
they always got that built-in excuse and
I know what you guys would think oh Bill
there you go with the conspiracy
theories and the conspiracy theories are
dumb are you one of those people that
thinks conspiracy theories are dumb
that everyone who thinks that is just a
paranoid lunatic with the [__]
tinfoil hat and all that just out of
curiosity how many more things have to
be Declassified how many more things
does the CIA then admit to doing this is
what was really going on 30 years
earlier but now that everybody's [__]
dead here you go
I got one for you guys to look up you
want to see something [__] wild that
that we were
um involved in look at I don't know if I
brought this up the other podcast the
Chilean coup d'etat
all right
and you know us America right bring us
your poor you downtrodden and all of
that and we're all about the [__] you
know freedom
that's why we're over in Iraq everybody
we're trying to free those people it's
an incredibly difficult job that's taken
over 20 years but that's you know
you know we kind of said it was this
then we said it was that and now we're
saying it's this like what what you know
eventually
they'll say the real reason why we're
over there right
so
back in like 2000 and this kind of like
no news coverage the CIA admitted
that 1973 they kidnapped the head of the
military down there
because that guy was going to support
the democratically elected leader
that the Chilean people had elected who
was a socialist or a communist and we
didn't like them so we kidnapped but
they made the decision that was the
government that they wanted
and we went in there kidnapped their
[__] guy and then supported this
absolutely brutal [__] dictator
who went in there and [__] killed
like 5 000 [__] people
and it happened on September 11 1973
they call it their 911. all right so
I don't know what to tell you
I say the NBA's fixed
everybody's [__] laughing at me
saying that next thing you know you got
a mobbed up [__] referee and what do
they do they act like it's just him like
he was shaving points and nobody on his
officiating crew had any [__]
understanding that it was happening the
amount of former NBA players that are
coming out talking about the script and
saying [__] like that and everybody just
go oh he's a bum he's out of the league
although those Bots or the [__] NBA
write [__] like that I'm telling you
there's a reason why all of them are
you know they're called entertainment
leaks
they're specifically done for done like
that because for some reason if they fix
a game the government gets involved
which is [__] hilarious like they're
not corrupt
the government gets involved and uses
them as like this example in this
distraction that they're actually
[__] you know paying attention to
what the [__] is going on
I know this is [__] dark right now
but what why the [__] is he going for
that field goal
is it really that [__] outright the
amount of decisions that have been made
in your lifetime where there's the right
thing and then there's the money and
that people always choose the [__]
money why would you think that this
would be any different why wouldn't you
why wouldn't you think
that at the end of the game
there was more money riding on [__]
the 49ers than there was on the Rams and
if they make that field goal Vegas wins
right and then they give the [__] the
NFL a little [__] kickback
let me guess that's [__] outrageous
that's outrageous even though you know
that they knew about CTE and the the the
effects of playing NFL football for like
50 [__] years and didn't do anything
about it and then when there was a class
action suit they settled out of court
with every former player and it came
down to about 750 bucks per player
you know that
but they are they they wouldn't do this
they wouldn't do this
all right we did that [__] down in Chile
in 73 and we wouldn't do that now that
was a long time ago ah you're a [__]
conspiracy theorist get the [__] out of
here
anyway
I also think it's convenient every
football game I'm just gonna go
conspiracy theory today
every football game the [__] camera
is never lined up with the goal line
there's another way to give them wiggle
room to fix a [__] game
oh Jesus
I'm going down a rabbit hole I'll tell
you another [__] thing I got you
another one I'm [__]
I'm wagging my finger at you do you guys
watch Colorado versus Colorado State
you know
and uh
somebody explained to me once again
that soft Zone cover too
that Colorado State goes into okay first
of all Colorado State
should have won that game like 10
different times just
they took so many stupid penalties I
don't know what they were [__]
terrible management
clock management
right
they're still up by [__] they're up
by eight
with a minute something left their
punter does his job coffin corner goes
out of bounds on like the two and a half
yard line with a minute 40 something
left and I'm watching the game and I'm
like Colorado is going to go right down
the field and is going to get four shots
at the end zone because that's how every
football game ends now
write down the [__] field
and guess what happened everybody they
went right down the [__] field
because Colorado State wanted to make
sure that they didn't get burned deep
they didn't get burned deep the whole
[__] game
so you give them chunks of yardage 20 25
[__] 30 yards every [__] play
right down the field
four opportunities
they score a touchdown they make the
two-point conversion and then they go
into overtime
in Colorado [__] wins
somebody explained to me convince me
that whatever that defense that they go
into at the end of the [__] game is
did not is not a marketing tool
I'm not saying that happens like every
[__] time
I mean I always say it happens every
time I know it doesn't happen every time
but that defense
when it comes to money
for the NCAA and the NFL
you put that defense in
okay the chances of having a heart
attack ending to the game
which means no [__] sports meat head
like me is gonna shut off the game
all right dude when I was a kid somebody
[__] put you in the corner like that
with a minute something left you a
[__]
you needed a [__] miracle to win the
game
I'd say now it's like 50 50 that they're
not going to go down the whole [__]
field
so back in the day you'd shut the game
off
you'd walk away from the TV and then
advertisers started bitching going like
well why do we have to pay this much
this amount of money at the end of the
game when you know the other team's up
by [__] seven points 10 points or
whatever the game's over
and then all of a sudden well all of a
sudden the prevent defense which fans
for years have said it prevents you from
winning that's the joke
and they still run it and I watched once
again
Colorado State instead of covering them
and playing defense the way they had
been
just made sure nobody got behind them
and then they went they went right down
the [__] field
um
by the way uh who doesn't love Deion
Sanders but like the level of hype
around that [__] team
I mean they had all they could handle to
be Colorado State Dion was on 60 Minutes
last night
to do with the fact that he's one of the
greatest football players of all time
and that how he took a college that you
know I'm trying to think the last time
I really remember them getting any
national coverage was when
um
oh my God I just forgot his name
they beat Michigan on the final play
with Cordell Stewart
there's a name Cordell Stewart the
former Steeler
um
that was the last time
and he's driven like ticket prices up
like that guy just packs stadiums and
I'm happy for him and I'm rooting for
him but like the level of [__] hype
but if anybody can handle
you know what I mean you're 2-0 in
division one college football and you're
already on 60 Minutes if anybody who can
handle
like that level of [__] hype
it will be that guy
I saw this thing man he took his [__]
sock off oh my God he goes oh my toes
are swollen up like sausages dude I
don't even know what his his foot like
looked like he had stepped on a landmine
like you couldn't even see his big
[__] toe first of all the whole side
of his
from the bunion down was like
was like the color of salmon
and the rest of his foot was was Dion
color
what was part salmon and his big toe
disappeared underneath this other one
it's just like
all the [__] that they can do
you know what I mean
they can give you bigger tits a fatter
ass
they can cut your dick off and turn it
into a vagina but they can't fix that
guy's foot
they can grow an ear in a petri dish
and they they can't get Dion's
I felt so so [__] I saw that I was
like God damn like
I don't want Dion walking around on her
foot like can we get this guy a new foot
I mean Sean McVay can kick a [__]
field goal you're still gonna lose the
game but it affects the [__] spread
and no one's gonna say [__]
everybody's gonna look the other way if
you can't get this guy in uh [__]
I would do a stand-up benefit
for Dion's foot that's how [__] bad
it was last time I saw a foot like that
believe it or not was Steven Tyler of
Aerosmith his feet are all [__] up
from dancing around on stage for 50
[__] years it's unreal man what
happens to your [__] body
um
by the way is there anything [__]
more ridiculous than all of these these
these stupid videos
on like Instagram about all these
stretches
and all this [__] and they all use the
exact like your back and they all use
the exact same sound effect
you know they're like hey you know you
this is best stretch you're like they
[__] cross one leg over the other one
and then they [__] twist their body
and hear this like their whole [__]
back just cracked and then you get on
the floor and like literally nothing
happens
it's like what do you like
that sounds like Bugs Bunny like sound
effects
um
anyway this is just the ramblings of a
man that went two and two who thought
there was a possibility he was going to
go 4-0 but I will tell you this
I will tell you this that um
it's not a good look for the NFL that
you are making money off of sports
gambling and Sean McVay kicks a [__]
field goal down by 10 points with four
seconds left
just to [__] do it
well you know you never know I don't I
don't think I've ever seen a [__]
season end and it came down to point
scored when the [__] does that happen
um
anyway
uh shout out to Tua with his [__]
little uh passive aggressive shade he
goes you know we never take you know the
Patriots lightly you know coming in here
beating them five times in a row you
know there's still Bill belich he slid
that in there I was like I didn't not
beat us five times in a row
good looking son of a [__] she [__]
threw that right in there didn't he
um
my only complaint about the old Patriot
uniforms is I just wish they would wear
the black cleats go all the way back to
gym plunket days
um
whenever they wear those those old Pat
Patriot [__] uniforms
I always start thinking about like uh
like every number number I see and it's
amazing how I can just recall those
things
these are the names I would say in Horus
ivory
Don Calhoun Tim Fox
all of these numbers that I was seeing
somebody's wearing Steve grogan's number
which I cannot [__] believe
the amount of hits that that guy [__]
took
oh which by the way I told you I was
over in Europe
and they're banning that that Turf
they're saying that it causes some sort
of uh cancer
because those pieces of Tire there's
lead in them
you know I wonder how long it's going to
take the NFL to talk about that it took
him a long time with the CTE oh look at
me I'm gonna get like the [__] NFL
CIA after me this week
[Laughter]
um
anyway I got kovid
I don't know if I got it on the flight
back but uh this is the second time I
had it I had in January
of last year
and then everybody around me kept
getting it
and I just wouldn't get it and then I I
finally got it and both both times it
just felt like a cold so I'm really
happy that I never got that covid-19
[__] like I have a relative of mine
never got their sense of smell back and
I got another buddy of mine that like
you know because every once in a while
my short I have shortness of breath so
I am relieved that this thing has
continued to mutate
to now just being this
um
and the two things that I love most I
love with how the left is acting like
when they were canceling people that
they weren't taking out innocent people
and it wasn't like any sort of like
power grab after a while they didn't
completely abuse their level of power
and be actually become fascist on one
level I love seeing that with the left
and I love watching the right now acting
like they were right when it came to the
pandemic
when they did absolutely nothing to try
and prevent catching it and spreading it
and acting like that behavior didn't
kill people because covid-19 killed
people and they're going to walk away
from all that they'll be like see it
didn't matter it didn't matter whether
you [__] do you know nothing [__]
it's like no you were selfish [__]
which was funny to me because all of
their guns guts and glory and support
the troops then it was like Hey can you
put on a mask they're like I can't
breathe
[Music]
[Laughter]
spike in gallons of milk in 7-Eleven I
don't want to wear a mask ask I mean it
was literally
like you ever see like a toddler when a
mom's trying to come on you gotta wear a
hat It's Cold Outside they don't want to
do it and they throw like a [__]
temper tamper I will never understand
that
um
do you think the Illuminati wants to dig
their own ditches they they [__] want
us to live
[Laughter]
um
anyway
so I think today is the day I stopped
being uh
I stopped being contagious but um
anyway what are you gonna do I mean it
was [__] worth it I mean I guess you
run around all over Europe
something's gonna happen
um
so whatever everybody believes what the
[__] they want to believe okay I think
the [__]
NFL I think all sports uh not all sports
but I think a lot of them they are
[__] massaged all right I believe in
all of that [__] I believe that the
owners of baseball knew everybody was on
steroids there's no [__] way that
they didn't they knew that they needed
to do something because they had
canceled the entire 1994 season it's a
marketing thing we need people to get
interested again all we have is Cal
Ripken Jr beating Lou Gehrig now that
we've done that how can we build on this
let's just look the other way and when
we get caught we'll just act like we
didn't know it was [__] happening I
believe that I think they Juiced up the
[__] ball
I I [__] 100 believe all of that I
think the NBA
you know was on their way to going out
of business and then accidentally
organically two super teams came about
in the Celtics and the Lakers and that
has been their business model ever since
um
and you know
I think the NBA's the most easily rigged
game and I think it is
uh and to be honest with you I don't
know why I'm still watching oh that's
right I have nothing better to do
from my pitch money complaining having
said that
I'm gonna watch again I'm gonna watch
again next week
you know
um
have I even talked to you guys about
doing the uh
the Acropolis I didn't
I did not I did the theater at the
Acropolis
in Athens Greece
the uh first stand-up show that they
ever had there
um
Nate Craig went on first so he's the
first stand-up comedian that they've had
there probably since the original ones
and it was
um
I got to tell you right before I was
doing the gig I was not excited about it
whatsoever
I was all grumpy and I was like
you know I was missing my kids and
everything and I was like what the [__]
why the [__] did I go over here for this
long what I should have done was just
come over here for four days and ended
with the grease thing and come back
and then I was feeling guilty like I'm
doing this thing I don't feel excited
and then the second I got there and I
heard the crowd I was like oh my God
the [__] hair stood up in my arms and
um
I can't did I tell you guys this
I don't remember
I'll just do a quick version of it
um
it's the loudest venue I've ever been in
it's louder than Madison Square Garden
or the Forum
trying to think about the loud venues
that I've been in
the Chicago Theater it's just louder
than them I can't explain it like uh
Nate Craig was saying
he was I think because when you do like
a theater or an arena there's an upper
deck and then there's a lower deck and
there's that space in between and with
this [__] it was just like a wall of
people it just went up it was four
thousand people 180 degrees
from one ear to your other ear and you
just went out and it was just this wall
of [__] sound
and it was effortless
like I totally took my time
they understood every single joke
it was like
my
yeah I was on stage at one point I was
actually thinking about Google Maps
and like where I'm standing right now
and it's like I'm literally and and then
what I do for a living like how it all
like [__] started
you know in a place like this
um
didn't I talk to you guys about I can't
remember
I will say like I was at the airport
and I kept calling them Aristotle it's
Aristotle is that what it is
the philosopher
I read a bunch of his quotes
and
the amount of [__]
that he said that as a human being you
kind of figure out
you know if you're working on yourself
like
I think like the beginning of your life
you don't know what the [__] going on
you get two parents hopefully you get
some cool ones if they're [__] crazy
that's just gonna add to the what the
[__] recipe
and then you're gonna get in into school
and then you're just kind of like
um
all right I want to be I want to fit in
I want to do what everybody else is
doing and then you do that to you like
30 and then you're like why aren't I
happy and then somewhere along the line
you settle into you start figuring out
what actually makes me happy
why am I doing this and you I kind of
realize that you've been sent down this
[__] road
you know with with it's almost like a
river but it's of human beings and you
just start following them like why am I
I don't want to do this and then you
kind of figure out
what makes you happy this guy's [__]
quotes they were unreal like every
single one of them like you can still
apply it
today like
[__] deep thinkers over there and I
was thinking like I can't believe I just
played
did Aristotle ever have a gig at the
[__] I don't know
we have Shakespeare all of those people
used to [__] bore the [__] out of me
when I was in school
um I don't know I'm sorry I just had to
go blow my nose
um
anyway it was an unbelievable gig and uh
there's no [__] way if I get an
opportunity that I won't do that again
it was absolutely fantastic and I'm
thinking the next time
the next time uh I go over there
I think I'm gonna keep going east
I keep running into people from Bulgaria
going we got you got fans there man you
got to go there it's like all right when
the [__] am I ever gonna go to Bulgaria
you know and that's one of those places
like you never hear on the news
like they have a bad publicist or maybe
they're just smart
they just stay out of [__]
which I gotta tell you living in my
country is very Envy I'm very envious of
that
like I like how Canada just stays out of
[__]
unless we drag him into something
foreign
like their older brother that likes to
fight and they're going out like come on
man let's just go to the movies let's
just [__] hang out and then we're
like [__] do you say to me and I think
we got beef with somebody
um oh bill would you stop
oversimplifying everything well I'm a
simple man
I'm a simple man uh anyway
so the Pats are [__] Owen too
the Buffalo Bills came back like you
like you knew they would
um
they're one in one dolphins
are 2-0
and the Jets are one and one
so
that's the division I'm watching
am I gonna [__] sneeze or what I feel
like I've I've been having to sneeze
here
isn't what do I stare at the light now
there we go
anyway let's do the [__] reads here
for this week
oh you know what before I do that you
know I don't like getting in the middle
of the [__] with like other performers
but I also have to stick up for writers
there's a certain performer that's going
back to his show
who said something that I don't even
understand why you would even say this
said that writers are not owed a living
and he was painting writers out
like
like this sitting around collecting
welfare
like there's writers out there that
don't actually write on a show and when
they're in that situation they still
want to get paid
that's not the issue whatsoever and he
was also painting it as though the
cameraman on his show weren't making any
money because of the selfishness of the
writers
you know take putting it all on the
[__] writers like they're they're
being selfish it's they're not the ones
that are being greedy
I just I cannot [__] believe I just
cannot believe statements like that
um
and then also outside of this business
watching people saying who cares who
gives a [__] it might be robots or
whatever Bots or whatever they call them
but like I can tell you this like I'm
rooting for the Auto Workers Union the
same way I'm rooting
for uh the wga I'm rooting for all
unions right now because we are in a a
new Robber Baron error
with these [__] [__] the amount
of money that they're taking I work for
[__] corporations that like
you know entities that book my stand-up
shows that on paper recorded a loss and
didn't pay any taxes and Meanwhile my
point person in that Corporation is
buying their second mansion in LA it's
just I don't feel like anybody is
watching these people whatsoever the
level of greed that is going on those
[__] bonuses that they're allowed to
give themselves at the end of the
[__] yeah of a bonus you know and
then but it has to go by the board and
the board is all of them and they all
approve it the same way like the
Senators and House of Representatives
they all get to [__] decide whether
or not they can be prosecuted for
insider trading they both make six
figures a [__] year yet most of them
are worth 20 million dollars I mean it's
just completely out of control
so
so those were some really
just ignorant [__] uh
just really ignorant [__] statements
and I I feel like
you know writers are literally the
skeletal system of this whole [__]
business
and you know
any great movie you've ever seen any
amazing thing that you've ever watched
if someone didn't write the [__]
thing
you know what you have even the [__]
Real Housewives
even that [__] with uh just reality TV
let's start shooting they're like this
is a [__] mess we have 9 000 hours of
footage we need somebody to come here
and mold this thing it's called a writer
and the fact that they just they're just
not even all they're asking for is a
[__]
you know I don't think what what what
they're asking for is ridiculous it's
just these [__] [__] they literally
want to just break the union they're
like we're not going to negotiate
or just pretend to negotiate until these
writers start losing their apartments
and their houses
like that's what they're going for I
gotta be honest with you man like I I
think
you know
I look at this where my business is at
right now and just the level of [__]
greed and what they've gone back to like
these streaming services like back
before
you know all of these actors these
childhood actors and everything had to
fight all of these fights to get
residuals
you know they would do a show and back
in the day the second the show was over
they would never get paid again and
these people that owned the shows would
get paid forever then these actors would
be Typecast and then you know they
couldn't get work and it was like they
kept making money off of their
performances why shouldn't they and they
had they fought for all of this and then
these streaming services came around
and I think our Union [__] up we
didn't hold them to that and they went
around they went around it and it's like
you do a show now for a streaming
service and it's like you basically have
the same deal that some child star had
in the 1950s
where it's like all right you're gonna
make this you're gonna get paid once and
that's it and then it's going to
continue to show and we're going to get
on our Network and we're gonna continue
to make money but you're not is the deal
that most people have and um
I don't know I think that they want to
do that and then I also think that
[__] AI shift did you see how the NFL
had like [__] four AI robots was that
real they just stuck them into the crowd
so people will get used to them
and here's the thing I guarantee you
they will get used to them
the second they find out they can [__]
them that's gonna be over that's gonna
be [__] Wild
all right
when you're going through the ups and
downs of a relationship
and you can go out and buy okay man or
woman here all right I'm not being a
sexist pig here even though I am one
man or woman you can go out and get a
[__] replacement that's gonna be like
a dog that's always going to be happy
when you [__] come home it's gonna do
whatever the [__] you even more so than
a dog even a dog hey what are you doing
yeah
yeah get that out of your mouth you know
you don't have to deal with that
oh my God
and it's gonna be [__] you can get it
younger and better looking totally
superficial
you know
and then you know what's gonna happen is
these [__] people are gonna fall in
love with these things
and at first human beings are going to
make fun of the humans and then after a
while
the other people are going to consider
themselves some sort of a minority and
then they're going to start [__]
complaining
that their love with their robot should
be recognized
all right
and then somewhere along the line the
robot is going to get rights
okay so they can have control again so
then a robot they'll make the new ones
like you know AI the AI 14 it might want
a divorce
you know add some excitement
into you you know your human machine
[__] relationship I mean I don't
I don't know I'm fighting myself I think
there's a reason why I spend most of my
day
at my house now and I just sit on the
back porch because I feel like the front
porch is life
or the front or the front of my house
that's I could look out there and I just
look out and I don't understand what's
going on but if I just sit in the back
and I look at the trees you know it's
it's nice and slow for old freckles
that's what it is I'm in the final
[__] third of this journey right 55
yeah that's about right right final
third of this [__] if I'm lucky
and uh
yeah you want it to slow down you just
want to sit there have a cup of coffee
read a newspaper
talk to some oh my God if you want to
hear like old people conversations
I'm never going to get to the
advertising this week
um
and by the way when I was talking about
the the things that that person said
even if you know who it is I think it's
really important for fellow performers
to not be going at each other
you know name calling and saying that I
think it's real it's really
disappointing
um an uninformed
like that's you know which I've been
enough in my [__] life so I don't
know that's just my take on it but
I also know there's a lot of writers
right now [__] struggling and to see
a fellow Entertainer or a couple of them
cross the line like that it's got to be
demoralizing so
I I I'm just saying that as a performer
I need you guys
just like everybody else F is for family
I had a killer [__] writer room my
[__] writer's room was [__]
killer the writing on
um the Mandalorian like all of this [__]
where you guys [__] like
send me emails and texts or whatever the
[__] DMs
oh my God that you know that [__]
you know that scene of the Mandalorian
when my my character had
PTSD and all uh whatever the [__]
whatever the [__] I can never say
that right post-traumatic stress PTSD
yeah
um you think I came up with that [__]
you think I just improv that
I didn't
they did
they and they didn't just come up with
that
that is hours and hours and months and
months of [__] work and they came up
with that
and and fleshed out my character
and because of that I got to play that
beautiful scene because of them
and the amount of people that love that
scene
and related to it
um
you know any movies you've seen me in
and all of that it's just like you know
okay there's some improv that goes on or
whatever but like you know you you have
to you it's easy to [__] improv when
you have a script
because you can go back to it's the same
thing doing stand-up I have us I have an
hour-long act that I have and I'll [__]
around everything but I can go back you
know if it starts getting into the weeds
I can go back to that thing so
um you can't
there's no way to overvalue writers
you know like I said all right I'm done
with that [__]
um
all right where am I going here uh
was I gonna just talk about oh well you
know why don't I do the [__] reads I
am required to do that at some point oh
I think I was talking about the old
conversation I was having
I don't want to read this because I want
to read other people's texts but we we
were talking about
um
this person's a couple years older than
me
and it was just basically a conversation
this person was saying like have you
noticed like nothing's kind of cool
anymore
and we both laugh and go like maybe
because we're old we don't know what's
cool and I'm like well there's got to be
something that's cool
but like I think the problem is now if
if something is cool
like you have the ability to immediately
film it and then share it with everybody
and then everybody sees it
like
you know
let's just go like basic here like the
[__] Walk
all right my whole the whole I I never I
had never seen that [__] thing until
like Snoop and Dr Dre hit one of them
put it in a video
and I thought it was like the coolest
[__] I'd ever seen right but that was it
you know what I mean now
there's people like on Instagram or on
YouTube and they will teach you how to
[__] Walk
so now there's like
white people my people are making videos
of themselves in the suburbs
doing that [__] dance and then people
from where it comes from is saying like
hey you better not do that that like
they don't understand the whole
I don't know Logistics I will say
that like if you go down there and you
do that and you're not a [__] you're
going to get [__] up
but because they live out in the suburbs
next to a TJ Maxx and a [__]
Cheesecake Factory and it's just like
it's like that type of stuff like back
you know when I was coming up before all
these phones and everything because I
definitely think obviously look I can
talk to you guys and joke around and
promote my show so it's not all bad here
but like um
you know like scenes could like develop
and what made them cool is nobody knew
what you know
they were just sort of like I brought
this up a while back when I was like
reading about
uh Beastie Boys when they were coming up
in New York and they were down in
Tribeca and there'd be all these like
that whole part of town you know when
the business day went over would be over
would just shut down and they would but
there would be these clubs that would
pop up
and it'd be like walking through like
you know Escape From New York they'd be
like nobody there and you come around
the corner and all of a sudden there was
just this little club and like nobody
knew about it and
all the music the fashion the art and
all of that could like incubate
you know and develop into the scene and
become this cool [__] thing before
the corporate Corporation would come
down and and [__]
Mass marketing like it like it did with
everything like with every music scene
um
like from disco to metal to grunge
you know I feel like somewhere around
grunge they learned how to they like the
marketing things was starting to get out
of control like that was one of the last
like I I feel like music scenes of my
youth that I remember the Seattle scene
and then for half a second with green
day they all they got like all the a r
guys were like oh well maybe in San
Francisco Green Day let's go find some
uh them now just sign bands from San
Francisco like that's kind of like what
they would do
it all comes down to how like you know
I always wonder what what you know Che
Guevara if he had lived would have
thought about how his face was mass
marketed onto a t-shirt in America
laughs
I mean just the fact that you would have
his face on a t-shirt I don't think you
lined up
with what he was talking about which I
don't really even know what he was
talking about I just know I think he was
against what the [__] we were doing
I don't know
but I do know when I was in New York
when I first came down there and I kept
seeing shirts like that and I felt out
of place I was like I was thinking I
should get one of those shirts
all right
let me uh let me take you down cause I'm
going to
Portland Maine on September 28th all
right
here are some gigs I got to tell you
about that are almost sold out but there
are a few tickets left September 28th
Portland Maine my old stomping grounds
uh what the [__] was that the comedy
connection I used to play up in Portland
Maine
uh
uh oh my God I remember that comedy club
one time the whole weekend is [__]
stunk and then they finally figured out
there was a dead rat right above the
stage
oh it's stoked for [__] weeks
uh you go up there to do a goddamn guest
spot that's what it was that wasn't a
good that was the old
Portland comedy connection
I'm not trashing that comedy club people
if you want to go see a show that
doesn't have a dead rat above it come to
the
the Cross Insurance Arena Portland made
on September 28th on October 1st
Springfield Massachusetts at the Mass
Mutual setup
wasn't I just there
I was literally just there the [__] I'm
like no no I'm not selling tickets
October 4th State College Pennsylvania
I'm doing a college gig those are always
fun at Bryce Jordan Center
I feel like we're out of that time now
and we blamed college kids and I think
it was really
uh
older Generations October 7th Canton
Ohio at Tom Benson Hall of Fame Stadium
October 28th Reno Nevada at the Reno
Events Center
November 7th Norfolk Virginia at Scope
Arena
November 8 Atlanta Georgia State Farm
Arena November 10th New York City at
Madison Square Garden November 17th Las
Vegas Nevada at Dolby live
I will be at all of those places with a
brand new Act
doing whatever it is that I do all right
let's uh
oh no what did I do
did I get rid of it did I get rid of the
document that had all of the [__] that I
needed to read
I think I did
[__] [__] all right
well what do I do now I go back to the
email
yeah I got to do the emails here okay
here we go here's the one read below
one read below also please plug false
shows with limited tickets remaining all
right I did that
um oh look who it is everybody it's all
zip
recruiter
uh did you know that if you're an
employer who's hiring the average cost
per hire is four thousand seven hundred
dollars
if you're investing that much money into
each new hire you want to get it right
so
what's the most effective way to find
the best people for your roles well it's
all zip
uh see for yourself right now you can
try for free at ziprecruiter.com and
experience the value zip recruiter
brings to hiring uh ZIP
lets you try before you commit there's
no cost to try zip disease
uh you can post it how many times do
they say [__] zip recruiter in this I
run out of ways of saying it uh you
could post jobs for free so you can see
for yourself how effectively how
effective zip
was it Jerry Lewis one is it helping you
higher Lady it's simple sip recruiter
helps you get hiring right four to five
employers who post uh get a quality
candidate within the first day see for
yourself go to this exclusive web
address to try ZipRecruiter for free
before you commit ziprecruiter.com again
that's ziprecruiter.com spell outbur
b-u-r-r sip recruiter
the smartest way to hire
the smartest way to hire all right we
have I evidently we have some great
emails this week
from the listeners
all right best meal in Europe
hey Billy tits did you go off the rails
in Europe
no I didn't I actually hit the gym a lot
I look great you [__] [__] he goes I
picture you eating dollops of Rich cream
and then bitching about your shoulder
preventing you from getting back in
shape my shoulder feels great
I look great
all right I'm turning it around the
green shirt diet
is back in effect even though I haven't
been able to go because I'm I'm still
contagious
uh I mean that with love oh okay I
thought you would be in a [__] all right
so I take back everything I said uh
what's the best food you had
and was and in what country oh Jesus
the best food I had
all right one of the first nights
I didn't write these places down I had
this amazing food in Dubai
oh God it was [__] incredible
it was all that kebab
Middle Eastern style food it was
fantastic the atmosphere was great and
um
which by the way I heard that they were
thrilled with the show and said I can
come back whenever I wanted so that's
[__] great I'm gonna go back there at
some point to see Moto GP or F and F1
race
um when I was in Prague
Bianca christophile took us to a place
that in Czech
means side piece
I swear to God something like that
and all I had there was this charcuterie
board
and the meat and the cheeses the [__]
I gotta tell you something
for a fat [__] country like my country
and how much we love cheese oh do we
love cheese our cheese here [__]
sucks
this cheese I had just at that place
this was just like a bar people smoking
cigarettes having a glass of wine
they brought this cheese out
and it like my eyes almost rolled in the
back of my head when I was eating it it
was like each one was better than the
next the meat was so fresh and all of
that you know our food over here is
poison
it is what it is but you know they paid
off the right people in the government
they look the other way so what they do
is they make sure you know major sport
sporting events aren't fixed and
stand-up comedians don't tell jokes the
way they don't like them that's what
they do
that's how they make up for that
um
and any candidate that can help you is
immediately branded as a fringe
candidate
um
okay there was that place and
let me see here
then you know
Prague and Dubai were the two places I
had time in Greece and then we kind of
like that we just became one-nighters
and um
in uh Berlin Stockholm in Budapest
like
all I you know what I found in those
places that I do remember
was places to get coffee so why don't I
give you those
let's see if I can find those
places to go
I gotta scroll by all the American
cities
Oakland Lois the pie Queen
there's something Rhode Island Warwick
ice cream I'm just gonna give random
shout outs
um
Tampa the Bad Monkey Bar I don't even
know what half of this [__] means or if
they're even still around after covet
um all right here we go let's let's get
it okay here okay
oh there's a place called parlor that's
right that we had breakfast
at that was fantastic this is an uh
czechia
it's not the Czech Republic anymore
check yeah
Ari Espresso Bar
unfucking believable [__] coffee the
man is an artist Henry
h-e-n-r-i Espresso Bar
um
and let's see
oh I didn't get a chance to go there
Berlin cats orange that's the last time
I went there slow cooked pork beef or
lamb stew
uh
uh when I was in Greece
uh mocha m-o-k-k-a 100 year old Coffee
Joint oh my God it was [__] unreal
and when I was in Budapest
uh for coffee
I went to my little Melbourne
or Melbourne as they say in Australia
and get the piccolo latte
so there you go that's that's what I did
I was mainly just doing coffee and
trying to eat light when I was over
there
now where the [__] is where the hell's
the other reads here all right uh die
Miami cops oh this was this was the
great bad movie that I watched on the
plane uh which by the way the Criterion
channel has uh 70s cop uh car movies
and I finally saw Steven Spielberg's
first movie Duel
and I thought when I was gonna watch it
I always got to see because it was his
first movie I thought I was going to see
like hints of the great director that he
was going to become the legend that he
is and this [__] movie right on he
was one of these guys right out of the
gate he was great
it's an absolutely gorgeously shot movie
um
if I ever had an opportunity to meet him
I would ask him like how does the script
work how do you sell this movie because
there was so little dialogue in it and
so much of it was a guy driving a
a car get menaced by this big old
1955 truck I actually looked up all the
cars and trucks that were in it and [__]
gorgeous movie
um and then I also saw this French movie
traffic that was [__] hilarious
and had all of these really really cool
uh European cars from 1971 in France it
was fantastic uh they also have
Thunderbolt and Lightfoot uh
uh Was it crazy Harry and something Mary
I saw that one a long time ago
with uh Peter Fonda
uh any Town's a good time when you bang
a broad was that movie you got to check
that one uh but check that out on the
Criterion Channel all right die Miami
cups okay first of all great show in
Prague Nathan Bianco also killed it yeah
they did that was the Dream Team man
they were just they were [__]
destroyed my wife from Detroit and I
went on a day trip from my hometown
Munich next to us set people from
Slovenia Italy and Bosnia no way
people traveled from all over Central
Europe to you and everybody had a great
time ah that makes me feel great
um
if any of you guys were wondering
whether the audience was maybe too quiet
they were just concentrating trying not
to miss a single joke yeah we figured
out that that's what it was I thought
you guys are great
uh saying since English isn't their
first language it was a wonderful
experience for everyone you were talking
on your podcast about the die Miami cops
movie on the airplane that was a bad one
out of a series of dozens of films by
the same acting Duo yeah Bianca told me
she goes yeah those guys were Legends
over there she said believe it or not
but the two main actors Bud Spencer and
Terence Hill were were our 80s and 70s
European teenage action heroes
that's cool uh I believe that their
original movies were shot in Italian
trying to be more serious the German
language version however were always
dubbed in a more silly mode so they
became very appealing to young people
the same thing was also done with the
British cop show the persuaders uh with
Tony Curtis and Roger Moore silly
fisticuffs and loose lips in the German
language version uh the title die Miami
cops only means the Miami all the Miami
cops oh it was written in German
like Das boat die Miami cops I'm an
idiot I thought that they were killing
Miami cops
oh
and it's pronounced d Miami cops it's
the German plural article
oh so Das boat is because there was one
d-i-e-d is plural because cops is plural
I get it
look at that [__] learning something
here anyway hope this clears up the
confusion about the dying or killing
part that you were uh reading in the
title go [__] yourself absolutely it
does thank you
um
all right then then
their Fair titty bust
what is that uh hi Bill I'm obsessed
with the
Fair rodic history
and always looking to talk about it
because I suffer from egyptomania
the bust in Berlin you saw was
[Music]
nefertitis I don't know how to say it
I'm so stupid sorry it was found in
modern day
amarna don't you mean stolen like why is
it in Germany uh she was an 18th Dynasty
Royal and was running
about Egypt in the 14th century BCE her
story and family was kind of insane
uh I'm not going to try to keep saying
this persistent
they're fair to tease husband was one of
the most mysterious Kings
in all of ancient Egypt history oh is he
in the closet uh his name was
akinaten
uh anyway this guy turned Egypt upside
down and got rid of all the gods and
goddesses and introduced a single God
called aten oh it was named after him he
then shut down all the temples dedicated
to all the other gods and put all the
priests out of work
what a dick
after that he got rid of all the gods
and instilled the single God he he then
moved from the from the capital
fabies or tabies with a bunch of his
followers and built a new capital city
dedicated to the worship of aten the
city
armana ran for about 12 years until that
dude died the single God way of worship
was hundreds
and hundreds of years before
Christianity
uh oh yeah I mean there's no doubt like
Japan
India Egypt there was all kinds and
that's just the ones that I've been able
to learn about
were Advanced cultures
and have never been recognized in
Western history uh this single God was
the aten and it was the sun disk the sun
raised it was depicted with little hands
at the end of the sun rays and was the
world's first expression of monotheism I
guess that's just believing one God we
believe in one God the Father Almighty
the maker of heaven and Earth
uh
and sociopaths and all kinds of other
horrible [__] people that he doesn't
take any credit for he just blames it on
the devil uh uh
wrote all sorts of beautiful hymns for
his God it was wild times and this guy
was essentially a cult leader yeah I was
immediately thinking Dick Cheney
um
just having that sort of the the right
amount of
craziness lack of empathy and balls to
just be like I'm gonna mold this [__]
country the way I wanted to be
um
I just need the right front man
uh where was I uh he also introduced a
new style of art which Scholars call
armana period R it's incredible and that
is what neferty's bust is it was
sculpted by a man called fatmos I
apologize to all Egyptian people and
anybody who's into this art I don't know
how to say any of these names
uh I had had himself depicted unlike any
of the Pharaohs before him he had a
bunch of daughters with
referee oh that was his chick
that was his Queen
and they'd have themselves all depicted
in Daily scenes as a family none of the
Egyptian pharaohs had ever done that
before it was pretty wild stuff when you
see the depictions I'll leave some below
uh that is wild it's almost like the
first sitcom a reality show Family
when a cat that had died his successor
taught I love how you got a quick little
name abandoned
amarna the new city and moved everyone
back to the old capital
uh
uh tabs tabies Debbies Tut then got rid
of this single God and brought back all
the old gods ah that guy was an [__]
dad
he's rebelling
I like Ty he's going back to the old
school way tat was a boy at the time so
it would have been older advisors oh
that made all of that happen oh the plot
thickened so he didn't hate his dad
maybe they whacked his dad
his son was the famous King oh King Tut
but they're still unsure as to whether
neferty was his mother
that's that's all really interesting
love what you do Bill and always looking
forward to hearing you on Mondays and
Fridays go mummify yourself I will say
what I thought was hilarious I never
really thought about it
was
you know they've never been able to
figure out how the Egyptians built the
pyramids
to the point that they were just going
like maybe it was aliens
you know it's like why can't you just
say it was maybe the Egyptians knew [__]
that
you know Europe didn't know yet why
can't we just it
admit that maybe there was a culture
more advanced than us that kind of goes
against our whole like what we do here
at the school don't you see we don't do
that like our little [__] College
pamphlet
you know you know when they see the
Roman Coliseum they're like oh the
aqueducts did aliens do this they're
like no the Romans did it so you know I
would say the Egyptians did it
that would be my guess
uh how were they able to do that back
then because they were [__] more
advanced they figured something out that
that white Europeans didn't
God forbid they get credit
all right eerily similar laugh
dear Billy red tits how the hell are ya
uh been a fan for a while now and have
been listening to the MMP for around six
years in those years I have grown very
accustomed to your laugh
uh uh to your last both your normal
laugh and that stupid wheeze that you do
when you say something you find funny
uh listen every laugh I have is stupid
because it's coming out of this dumb
head
um the other day I finally put two and
two together when I realized that your
wheeze sounds exactly like
motleys from The Wacky Races you mean
the laugh Olympics
uh I'm sure you'll disagree with me I
wouldn't I love that guy but that's just
what dick dastardly's sidekick would
want me to believe anyway hope you Nia
and the kids are doing well thanks and
go [__] yourself
all right what do we got here a [__]
song
a [__] song
hey Bill I [__] hate
Take a Walk on the Wild Side by The
Velvet Underground all right this is one
of these things one of the like this
there's always those songs that
everybody loves and you love them too
but then there's some that everybody
loves and you don't understand
why does everybody love them I can see
why you'd hate that one
I'd say hey babe
Take a walk on the west side and the
color girls say do to do it doesn't even
sound like he's trying
he would that like that whole period The
Velvet Underground Andy Warhol and all
and they were sort of like the original
alt Comics I feel although I did listen
to a Velvet Underground album
uh and I was finally starting to get it
because there's a lot of that stuff that
I just I don't get it but I'm also
like hair metal totally makes sense to
me so just take it all with a grain of
salt uh anyway this person says I don't
care about its stupid poetic meaning or
that it's about heroin and horse
when it gets to the do to do to do part
I really just wanted him to take a walk
off a [__] cliff
[Laughter]
uh um I do like the saxophone solo
[Music]
um
which they ended up putting into like a
gene genes commercial I think it's like
20 years later was that in like a 501
blues commercial
uh song I Can't Stand
Hey Oh Billy Prince of bald redheads
long time listener here finally felt the
urge to write in you've had me cracking
up on the Monday Morning podcast for
years now but I've got something I need
to get off my chest have you ever
listened to uh hooked on a feeling I
mean really listen to it no I haven't
it's an absolute Banger of a track a
classic right but man every time
it kicks off with that hookah Chaka
Hookah Hookah Chaka I feel like throwing
my radio out the window I 100 agree with
that
like I don't know what
that hookah Chaka is that just sounds
like you know when we would write movies
about cavemen when they had their own
language like that Chaka from [__] uh
Land of the Lost that he would come in
hookah chatur and then the [__]
little blonde girl would be like you
know the Sleep stack are coming like
somehow could understand
the [__] language it was so stupid
she never spoke his though maybe she did
I don't know am I really gonna break
that down
anyway
this person says now
I get it it was the 70s people were
doing all sorts of weird stuff funky
pants Wild Hair who knows what they were
smoking what is opposed to now with
self-driving cars and Lead legal weed
that isn't even weed anymore you start
[__] tripping on it uh but come on
it's like ordering a fine wine and then
getting a rubber duck in it
uh
uh yeah it also I always felt it sounded
like really over produced
when he's going I can't find that
feeling it's like a wall of like Harmony
and there's this Reverb or something on
it that I always like uh
I gotta be honest too I never got past
hookah Chaka Uka Chaka I just sounded
silly to me
uh
but the person says every time it starts
I think about
I think I'm about to hear some lost
tribal chant or something and then oh
that's right it's just that song I mean
could you imagine it
if every great song decided to start off
with some bizarre chant
like
like hey remember Stairway to Heaven
yeah what if it kicked off with ribbit
ribbit ribbit ridiculous right
well that's more of a frog noise but I
know what you mean
um
now I know you appreciate a good rant
and I can't help but wonder what you
think about this is it just me maybe I'm
overreacting every time I hear
hookah Chaka I think of how much better
the song would be without it 100 percent
um that was that weird period of like
Cherokee People
Cherokee tribe and everyone was Kung Fu
Fighting
there was this whole weird
like karate movies us sort of finally
addressing what we have done to Indians
sort of but not really
you know you know you know Liberals are
liberals then just sort of make friends
with the oppressed group but then don't
really do anything to help them
and then when they get kicked off from
more land then they go I need to call I
need to check in with my Indian friends
to make sure they're doing how are you
doing I'm so sorry you lost more land is
there anything I can do
um
anyway keep up the great work on the
podcast looking forward to hearing your
thoughts on this absolute uh tragedy of
a song intro cheers from the Netherlands
I why you know
I don't think you're gonna really have
anybody argue with that I bet the people
in the band
you know I I you know what I'm actually
going to look it up I'm even over right
now I'm gonna look this [__] up
so this is what you have to guys you got
to look up the 1973 Chilean coup d'etat
and you also have to look up
why did they say who okay
why
did they chant
hookah
Chaka
see if this even comes out
okay what does in the first song by
Johnny Preston
ukachaka is basically some white backup
singers trying to sound like they're
doing an Indian I.E Native American war
chant
according to Wikipedia entry on Running
Bear the singer responsible for the Uka
Chaka is country western singer George
Jones
I love George Jones
Jesus Christ
what does ukachaka mean in these two
songs uh uh the first Johnny okay
yeah this is the same thing well there
you go
George Jones he's probably like hey
everybody damn people in uh helping out
the Native Americans let's just you know
throw some Indian [__] on that I don't
[__] know he didn't talk like that um
well there you go
yeah I would agree I think that that's
[__] terrible and it also
I know I think that song's only okay
and it doesn't really take me back to
the 70s because I never really heard it
until I want to say uh
Quentin Tarantino used it in a movie
I can't remember
did he use that in a movie
it was it the other one there's another
one that starts with he he has one movie
where they're driving away in a car
there's this really weird chant that's
clearly supposed to be from a different
culture but it's clearly white people
doing it I think
or maybe it isn't
I don't [__] know
I don't [__] know anyway I'm babbling
um I'm babbling I don't think I'm
contagious anymore
um all right that's it I'm gonna get on
with my day here I hope you guys all
have a great day sorry about all my
conspiracy theory but it's just uh I
don't know
it was a [__] tough Patriot loss
that's what I'm talking this podcast up
to
all right all right
I'll check in on you on Thursday